notre invité bruno me garbade chef des
service réanimation de l'hôpital
lariboisière grand défenseur de la
vaccination un bon soir bruno meyer
vannes merci d'être avec nous joe biden
qui déclarent aujourd'hui que cela
permettra donc aux parents de mettre fin
à des mois d'inquiétude et réduira la
transmission du virus par les enfants on
a vu la satisfaction de nombreux parents
américains c'était nécessaire pour vous
de franchir ce pas sans état d'âme
écoutez tout d'abord les études
scientifiques
pour le moment non publiées il faut le
dire en tout cas fourni aux autorités
sanitaires
heather et modern à effectuer sur
plusieurs milliers d'enfants semble
montrer que le vaccin est parfaitement
efficace et très bien toléré alors c'est
vrai qu'à ce jour
on va dire le nombre total d'enfants
finalement ayant reçu le vaccin reste
encore limitée donc on peut pas affirmer
définitivement
notamment en termes d'effets secondaires
rares que ceux ci n'existe pas par
contre évidemment
c'est un pas encourageant pour permettre
la vaccination des plus jeunes car à
nouveau cette tranche d'âge pour le
moment est la seule non vaccinés et
malheureusement le virus circule
essentiellement parmi les personnes non
vaccinées
l'institut pasteur estime par exemple
qu'à l'occasion du rebond de l'épidémie
que nous allons observer cet hiver et
bien 50% des contaminations auront lieu
chez les enfants or toutes personnes non
vaccinées risque d'abord de faire une
forme grave de la maladie il faut savoir
qu'en france aujourd'hui environ 50
enfants sont hospitalisés pour une forme
plus sérieuse de la commune 19 et que
les enfants sont malgré tout exposé aux
risques de copie que l'on est désormais
des études très sérieuses montrent là
l'entrée du virus du moins
l'inflammation de certaines régions du
cerveau en cas d'infection y compris
bénigne qui peut être à l'origine
d'ennui prolongé à brno mais germania
aussi
ce variant anglais qui se propage plus
rapidement
chez les enfants avec une augmentation
des hospitalisations
particulièrement sur les enfants
américains ce qui explique peut-être
moins de scepticisme là bas et un
accueil plus favorable à la à la
vaccination
alors vous avez raison il ya deux
différences importantes entre la france
et les états unis tout d'abord les
enfants américains souffrent avec une
prévalence plus importante de
comorbidité notamment d'obésité et on
sait par expérience que la cobac 19
atteint préférentiellement les personnes
obèses et il résulte en une forme un peu
plus grave de la maladie la deuxième
différence c'est que la couverture
vaccinale aux états unis est bien moins
bonne qu'en france aujourd'hui en france
environ
76 % de la population
éligible à la vaccination est doublement
vacciner ses 20 points de plus qu'aux
états unis et donc évidemment le fait de
vacciner les enfants aux etats-unis
contribuera quelques pas à réduire la
circulation du virus donc à protéger
indirectement les personnes plus âgées
et un risque non maxime thomas comment
réagissent les autorités locales à
l'ouverture de la vaccination des
enfants ont précisé aux états unis c'est
important de le dire qu'à part je crois
en l'état de new york il n'y a pas de
pas de sanitaires donc c'est une
obligation c'est pas une obligation qui
dit pas son nom comme ça peut l'être
vécu en france mais voilà une
proposition de vaccination
oui alors beaucoup de localités beaucoup
d'élus se sont félicités de cette
possibilité de vacciner les enfants
comme je vous le disais tout a déjà été
mis en place en réalité depuis quelques
jours pour permettre cette vaccination
mais il ya quand même des contestations
assez local on parle beaucoup on
beaucoup parler dans votre émission de
l'état du texas et de la floride qui
sont un peu à la pointe justement de
cette contestation contre les
obligations que ce soit en ce qui
concerne le port du masque en ce qui
concerne les obligations de vaccination
est d'ailleurs le gouverneur de l'état
de floride il ya quelques jours avant
que cette autorisation ne soit accordée
avait déjà affirmé publiquement qu'il
n'y aurait jamais d'obligations de
vaccination pour les enfants scolarisés
dans l'état de floride on sait qu'il est
déjà opposée au masque obligatoire dans
les écoles il veut laisser la liberté
aux parents parce qu'en réalité aux
états unis le débat au-delà de
s'articuler autour de pro ou anti
vaccins s'articule surtout autour de la
notion de liberté et que ce soit le
gouverneur du texas où le gouverneur de
floride ils veulent laisser la liberté
justement aux parents de décider ce
qu'il souhaite faire pour ce qui
concerne leurs enfants on a aussi vu
récemment des mouvements de
contestations y compris à new york vous
en parliez ou des pompiers notamment
sont en arrêt maladie en grand nombre
depuis plusieurs jours justement pour
s'opposer à l'obligation de vaccination
il est intéressant de noter que le maire
de new york qui vient tout juste d'être
lui a d'ailleurs dit que c'est très un
dossier sur lequel il allait se pencher
assez rapidement bruno m'égare ban c'est
vrai qu'à cinq ans on est vraiment
encore un petit bout de chou
il ya de nombreux parents qui sont pas
forcément anti vaccins y compris en
france qui seraient extrêmement inquiets
à l'idée de les faire vacciner
clairement je vous pose la question
est-ce qu'on a suffisamment de recul
pour prendre ce risque
alors je dirais on va dire aujourd'hui
je suis d'accord avec vous le recul est
peut-être encore on va dire minimaliste
il est vrai que je ne crois pas que les
autorités sanitaires en arrive à décider
d'une obligation de la vaccination y
compris aux états unis pour les enfants
de 5 à 11 ans à linverse très
progressivement et bien on va accumuler
des données parce que ben que ce soit
aux états unis à cuba en israël un
nombre croissant d'enfants de 5 à 11 ans
vont être vaccinés et donc on va pouvoir
voir un peu comme ça a été fait chez
l'adulte et bien les risques de
complications notamment de complication
rare vous avez parlé de mieux car dit on
peut parler peut-être de l'inflammation
multi systémique éventuellement de
problèmes de plaquettes s'il y en avait
et donc on va pouvoir voir ces risques
là à mon sens ils seront très faibles
mais on va pouvoir mieux mesurer la
balance bénéfice risque avant évidemment
d'entrer dans une campagne de
vaccination plus systématique des
enfants moi je suis convaincu qu'à terme
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire y
compris chez les enfants car c'est
malheureusement la solution unique
pouvoir sortir définitivement
de cette épidémie mais aujourd'hui je
suis tout à fait d'accord il faut encore
être un tout petit peu plus prudent les
données des laboratoires sont
extrêmement encourageantes le vaccin est
parfaitement efficace et surtout est
très bien toléré d'après leurs données
il faut encore attendre une augmentation
du nombre d'enfants vaccinés il faut
savoir d'ailleurs qu'en france environ
vingt mille enfants de 0 à 11 à 11 ans
ont été déjà vaccinés car c'étaient des
enfants à risque de faire des formes
graves de la maladie et chez ces enfants
en tout cas il n'a pas été signalé
d'effets secondaires de l'état
donc ça qu'on sent désormais au
une révélation fait beaucoup parler sur
ce même laboratoire aux états unis
où il s'agit d'une publication qui est
parue dans le british medical journal
qui donne la parole qui donne le
témoignage d'une ancienne directrice
régionale d'une entreprise qui s'appelle
vente à vias est une entreprise qui a
été chargé à partir du mois d'août 2020
de mener des essais cliniques au tour
justement du vaccin weiser ça se passe
dans l'état du texas et donc cette
ancienne directrice régionale explique
que de nombreux problèmes se sont
produits lors de ces essais par exemple
des manquements dans les essais censé
être réalisé à l'aveuglé qui finalement
ne l'était pas des consignes à des
employés pour modifier des données des
protocoles non respecté un manque de
suivi des effets indésirables chez
certains patients ou encore l'absence de
tests pcr pour justement des patients
ayant contracté des symptômes ducobu 19
alors cet ancien employé avait
rapidement avertit l'agencé américaine
des médicaments la f10 et mais elle n'a
pas été écouté par sa hiérarchie il a
même été licencié et depuis d'autres
employés semblent confirmer ces méthodes
toujours auprès du british medical
journal
alors il faut noter que ces accusations
concernent un laboratoire au texas qui
couvre environ 1000 patients sur
lesquels 44 mille personnes qui ont
constitué ces essais cliniques pour
l'élaboration du vaccin weiser alors il
ya évidemment une question sur le
contrôle des autorités sanitaires par
sur ces essais cliniques puisque sur les
153 sites où se sont déroulés les essais
cliniques aux états unis seuls neuf ont
été contrôlés par la f10 est et sur ses
neufs qui bien il n'y a pas la fameuse
entreprise vente avia qui est basé au
texas cela pose donc la question des
moyens mis en oeuvre elle par les
autorités sanitaires américaines pour
contrôler et pour faire toute la
transparence sur les essais cliniques
qui ont été faits dans le cadre du
vaccin de pfizer bruno meyer 20,9
souvent eu d'occasion ensemble voilà
vous avez fait des face à face avec
justement des gens qui n'avaient pas de
confiance au vaccin ce type d'histoire
alors elles sont peut-être isolé mais
tout même ce n'est pas de nature à
restaurer la confiance qu'est ce que ça
vous évoque quand vous entendez ce type
justement de 2 ici
je suis d'accord avec vous effectivement
lorsqu'on met en place des essais
thérapeutiques avec l'urgence que l'on
connaît lié à l'épidémie il peut y avoir
malheureusement des dysfonctionnements
il éventuellement y avoir des personnes
qui trichent en tout cas tout ça
nécessite des contrôles à ce jour je
pense que si les autorités américaines
de la f10 est agréé
que ce vaccin pouvait être utilisé chez
les enfants c'est qu'ils ont regardé de
très près l'ensemble des résultats et
qu'il n'y avait pas de on va dire de
doute quant à l'exactitude des données
fournies par le laboratoire il faut en
fait savoir que les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques fournissent au fur et à
mesure leurs résultats aux données
aux héros aux autorités sanitaires que
ce soit aux états unis en europe et même
en france la nsm regarde de façon très
régulière les résultats
donc je crois qu'il faut quand même
faire confiance aux autorités sanitaires
en tout cas pour l'adulte aujourd'hui
plus de
5 millions 5 milliards pardon de
personnes sur terre ont reçu des doses
de vaccin est donc évidemment s'il y
avait eu des problèmes il serait apparu
merci beaucoup en tout cas bruno m'égare
ban thomas bonnet en direct de
washington merci d'avoir été avec nous